1100 kilomètres par heure ça va très
vite c'est la vitesse à laquelle se
déplacent paris pendant que la terre
tourne sur elle même au niveau de
l'équateur
c'est pire celles et ceux qui habitent
en guyane et qui sont en train de
découvrir cette capsule de les confiner
se déplace à environ 1650 kilomètres par
heure
et pourtant on ne sent rien cette
étrange quand on est à bord d'une
voiture qu'on nous tend la main
l'extérieur on ressort le déplacement
c'est parce que le véhicule se déplace
en traversant les rangers on ressent les
molécules qui composent l'air s'écouler
sur la peau si on ne sent pas la terre
tourne et c'est tout simplement parce
que l atmosphère qui l'enveloppent se
déplace en même temps qu'elle comme tous
les corps qui nous entoure les molécules
qui composent l'air sont attirés vers le
centre de la terre par la force de
gravitation résultats l'atmosphère reste
scotché au plancher des vaches
d'accord mais cette vitesse vertigineuse
pourquoi ne la ressentons nous pas en
fait ce n'est pas la vitesse que nous
ressentons mais l'accélération
quand nous sommes à bord du tgv nous ne
sentons pas qu'il roule à 300 kilomètres
par heure
en revanche au départ quand il accélère
nous sommes plaqué contre le siège et
maisons des colons au moment où ils
freinent comme la terre tourne sur
elle-même à une vitesse constante
nous nous sentons rien et nous ne
ressentons pas non plus la force
centrifuge car elle est beaucoup plus
faible que la force de gravitation qui
nous plaquent au sol et j'espère que
tout cela ne vous aura pas tourner la
tête
si vous avez aimé cette capsule de des
conflits n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus
également voir ou revoir toutes celles
des jours précédents j'en réalise une
nouvelle chaque jour et pour être sûr de
ne louper aucune et bien abonnez vous et
activer la petite cloche à demain et
n'oubliez pas nous sommes toujours
peaufiner mais en restant lien